اعلن البيت الابيض ان الولايات المتحده
مستعده لتقديم كل المساعدات اللازمه
لتركيا لافتا الى صدور توجيه من الرئيس جو
بايدن في هذا الصدد بدورها روسيا ارسلت
ثلاثه طائرات تابعه لوزاره الطوارئ
الروسيه على متنها اكثر من 100 من رجال
الانقاذ والاطباء وفي السياق اعلنت الصين
عن تقديم دفعه الاولى بقيمه نحو سته
ملايين دولار كمساعدات طارئه لجهود
الاغاثه في تركيا
بريطانيا ارسلت فريقا من 76 متخصصا في
البحث والانقاذ وعبرت عن استعدادها لتقديم
مزيد من الدعم وقال وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه البريطاني انهم سيستخدمون كل شيء
من اجل ادخال المساعدات لشمال السوريه
مؤكدا مواصله دعم الخواذ البيضاء
والمنظمات الخيريه العامله كما قالت هيئه
الحمايه المدنيه الاتحاديه بالمانيا انها
ستقدم مخيمات ملاجئ طوارئ ووحدات لمعالجه
المياه
النمسا اعلن مستشارها عن ارسال 80 جنديا
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ وتقديم ثلاثه
ملايين يورو كما اعلنت الخارجيه
الاستراليه تقديم مساعدات انسانيه مبدئيه
بقيمه 10 ملايين دولار للمتضررين من
الزلازل التي ضربت تركيا والسوريه في سياق
متصل قررت قطر فتح جسر جوي لتركيا يضم فرق
انقاذ وطواقم طبيه ومساعدات اغاثيه وخياما
ومستلزمات وقالت الخارجيه القطريه ان نائب
رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اكد
لنظيره التركي خلال اتصال هاتفي وقوف دوله
قطر الى جانب تركيا للتخفيف من التداعيات
الانسانيه الخطيره للزلزال كما اعلنت
الكويت عن تسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
تقديم مساعدات واطقم طبيه عاجله وقال
العراق انه سيرسل فريق انقاذ وستين طنا من
المساعدات الاغاثيه والغذائيه والطبيه اما
باكستان فقالت انها سترسل طائرتين الى
تركيا على متنهما مواد اغاثه وسته وثلاثون
فردا من فرق البحث والانقاذ في الاثناء
اعلنت الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه ارسال
طائرتين الى تركيا تنقلان مستشفى ميدانيا
ومساعدات طبيه وانسانيه عاجله